Cause that's,
I agree exactly with what you just said.
So what I,
the views that I've come to and study
moral psychology is that we is that humans
are ultra social apes.
We evolved to live in these small groups
that are fighting with each other.
Uh,
we evolved to have these low
level animistic religions.
That's our steady state.
That's the way we were for at least a
hundred thousand years are much more,
probably closer to a million in some form.
Um,
so that's sort of our design.
That's what we were
designed for in a sense.
Um,
and in that sense were as individuals
really kind of stupid tribal creatures
designed to do post hoc reasoning.
Um,
but if you put us together in the
right way with the right checks,
with the right,
the right systems,
um,
the whole can be vastly smarter
than the components that go into it,
which is true of the brain,
to the brain is composed of neurons.
Each neuron is really kind
of stupid little switch.
We can put them together in the right
way and you get something really
brilliant.
And in the same way.
Um,
I don't know the history here,
but my understanding
is that science begins,
or the culture of science,
the scientific revolution
begins in Europe.
Uh,
in the 17th century.
As you begin getting,
you get the printing press so
people can share their ideas,
but you get communities of people who
are challenging each other's ideas.
And that's what makes it so brilliant
is that is that people have to do their
best.
We're really bad at this
confirming our own ideas.
It's very hard to make
it very hard to do that.
But you put your ideas out there and
then everyone else is motivated to
challenge them.
And so if you put us
together in the right way,
the truth comes out.
And so adversarial systems
of law journalists know this.
They have to listen to both sides.
Scientists know this.
Social scientists should know this.